i just had a terrifying thought what's
that what if the simulation is already
over
i mean it's just running now it's just
running its course no like yeah right
credits are rolling and that's why
everything's getting crazy right yeah
maybe
have you played civilization i haven't
no so in in civilization there's
multiple ways to get a victory for those
not familiar it's a video game where you
literally start from like
you know nomadic tribes and then develop
technology and then eventually you have
these big civilizations and you go to
war whatever
there's several ways to win there's like
a space race victory where you can go
and call on other planets
cultural victory where you become the
dominant culture of the planet war
victory by just blowing everybody up and
taking over their land
but once you beat the game you can
choose to just keep playing anyway
okay and then the game objective is done
and you're just doing whatever
so that's where you think we are yeah
maybe maybe this simulation ended a long
time ago because you know i was thinking
about like why was there a space race in
the 60s
what was the motivation of the united
states to say we must be
better than the soviets that we don't
have any of it today
it was it was honestly it was just fear
because
the american public thought that because
they were in space
they could spy on us from space so it
was it was
laced with fear of them being able to
you know shoot us from the stars
essentially you know right and that
that's what spawned it into
so you know it was pretty much fear that
led it into
the the new space so how have we how
have we come to this point where
everyone feels like they've beaten the
game where it's like you've got nothing
to do you're bored you're angry
there's no fear you've got food you got
video games
there's no purpose whatever you want at
the tip of your fingers yeah
no fear to be honest i think that's a
good point we were concerned for our
safety yep that's why we our security
wasn't guaranteed we had to strive to be
better to protect ourselves and now we
don't well that's why i want to talk
about chick-fil-a and it's like if you
don't know what that is
that is the asteroid that destroyed the
dinosaurs there's a layer
of of molten uh i don't know material
all around the world from the same time
period
and that's because it struck the the
planet and killed
99 of of life on on this planet
that can happen we see like there's a
comet flying by
right now if if it's nighttime where you
are go go outside and look
it's cool neo what is it called neo
something i don't know i don't know but
we
we we talked about the news of the of
the flybys yeah where like the orbit
gets
really close and it's like whoa it's
like you know
everyone's so desensitized by
armagadden the movie what other however
many other impact
deep impacts like clone movies oh yeah
yeah sure whatever it's just movies and
it's like
uh well yeah well that could actually
happen there's
we're we are flying through our sun
isn't
sitting in one spot it's flying it's
flying through space
we are we are traveling around a
traveling star
so we don't know if there's some a rock
out there that's
just floating that's going to enter our
our solar system
and run into our planet there was uh ao
mao now
yeah that was an interstellar object
that entered our solar system
orbited around the the sun one time and
dipped out
yeah i mean we got we got lucky
didn't hit us but those kind of things
exist so that could happen we
i'm not trying to like instill fear but
it is something that we that's why i'm i
love space space is
is something we we don't think about as
much anymore but it's out there like
the the immensity of what space is
so we we need a meteor false flag i mean
it
i guess you know we need her we need an
announcement where it's like
there's a meteor in the sky and we've
got five years to build interplanetary
defense
and then everyone comes together and
then it's like you know independence day
we will not go quiet yeah maybe it's not
gonna be aliens though it's gonna be
it's gonna be a meteor i feel like
that's
that's the largest threat to the planet
you know always at all climate change
didn't work
because we are floating through space
that that's like people stopped thinking
about it because it's just
you know moving what not they tried
climate change
right as the big grand apocalyptic event
and a lot of people don't we just had a
pandemic
and i couldn't even do it maybe we we so
we used to have fear behind us and a
family ahead of us
yeah now they're taking our families and
there's no fear behind us that's a good
point maybe it's because we have no
families
nobody there's nobody going like no fear
no families great
think about it the fear is gone
yep for some reason that even though
we're watching in california they're
forcefully
injecting hormones into this kid people
are still saying well you know i'm
worried about my kid so i'll just do
nothing
no but for real like aren't you scared
for your children i would be
people aren't they're like well i i am
in the sense that i could lose my job
but not in the sense that the future is
going to be a nightmarish dystopian
hellhole
that i'm okay with there's no fear about
what that lead what you leave for your
children why not
because we're taught to to worry about
yourself
yeah man that's what we we are told you
can be anything
you you're a star you can you can do
whatever you want and
you know move out of your family home
you know get your own place if you still
live with your parents like you're
you're
you're not an adult yet you know you got
to live on your own you got to be your
own person
so it's like the community of how humans
have gotten to where we are is being
lost i feel like
when you raise people to be
self-centered yeah
but they still have their natural
instinct to protect their kids
you get what we have today no real fear
for the future their children will
inherit
good but a general fear for their
immediate safety yeah yeah it's dread
of the present if if we were scared that
like what if the soviets built a
satellite that could launch
you know what are they called rods from
god the tungsten rocks tungsten
balls of your city and then everybody
dies and that scared them and said we
must defend ourselves but today
they're like what if these people
literally inject my children with
hormones and then arrest them for saying
naughty words
right oh you know i don't know
we're not gonna say anything or like the
i hate bringing this list up but
it's on that list that says well we have
this story oh
the media is still oh this oh this
they're talking about it aren't they
this is the yeah calling it calling out
white culture
but calling out the the bias training
people as as racist
well i guess but before we get to that i
just wanted to say on that list
that i guess we're about to talk about
it says delayed gratification
is something that they're damning like
it's a bad thing it's like
that is exactly the problem we
if if it's just instant gratification
you're not getting anything you're not
doing anything
right you're just that's you know that's
playing
you know the the worst games just you
know
it in every aspect of your life just to
get it
get it now instead of thinking about
your children
why do you think all these people who
have a lot of money that they're
traveling
i'm bringing up the trump thing about
how his grant his dad
like furthered this thing and it's like
sure generational wealth well if you are
thinking
and jealous of generational wealth start
the generation
delayed gratification is knowing that
your grandchild is going to be better
off because of what you're doing
right now a society grows great when
people plant trees whose shade they know
they will never
they will never sit in where's that from
it's like i think it's a greek proverb
but i think is that greek it couldn't be
couldn't be more true though yeah but
nobody believes it anymore
right because we're comfortable no but i
think because we've been raised to be
selfish
yep yep man think about how comfortable
and selfish
it used to be all for the kids yep now
it's all like
i guess i have kids whatever well
there's a there's a compelling argument
to be made that the reason that we're so
selfish because their parents worked
their butts off so that we could have
the best life
ever like literally the best life that
anyone's ever had that was our parents
goal that was their parents goal after
world war ii they came back and they
were like
we have to make life really good for our
kids that's what i'm saying we won we
beat them
yeah man they did i know my dad worked
his butt off too we
we beat the game the last two like two
generations ago was when the game screen
popped up and says congratulations
you've won
you've created the best possible life
for your children would you like to keep
playing anyway
and they just set the controller down
and and they
pressed autoplay and like whatever yeah
i'm gonna go i don't really care
yeah make a hot pocket you ever see that
story about the dude who left
uh he had like a a a civilization game
from like
it was running for like 20 years or
something it was a
really funny story was like civilization
two from the 90s okay
and apparently he had been playing the
game for 20 years and it was a
post-apocalyptic wasteland of constant
nuclear bombs going off
oh man because people would just the war
could never end because the hatred ran
so deep
and every time they nuked a city the
nuclear waste would make it impossible
to recover
but then they would all just build
another nuke and then nuke each other
and it was just
the year was like 20 000 and it was a
nightmarish
what if that's where we're going man no
we beat the game
we did it we've got the best lives we
got instant communication we got running
water clean water
now not for the rest of the world but in
america yeah the universe is out there
the entire universe yeah man we're a
pale blue dot
thank you carl sagan people need to
watch him people need to know their
history they got to
know what we need an energy revolution
it's happening
what's the latest solid state batteries
well that's
that is actually an amazing innovation
that has happened
you know that's gonna that's gonna
change the game it is yeah i think
it allows they don't degrade that's the
key exactly yeah that's the key and they
don't blow up and they don't blow up
exactly
yeah those two things are fairly
important those are yeah incredibly
who were kidding yeah it's incredible
but i mean it's it's not necessarily
enough for the energy output we would
need for like
the the current level of you know
well carp there's um gravity graphene
is another big thing that they just
figured out me and ian talk about a
bunch it's uh
we can basically take any carbon based
anything and turn it into graphene and
graphene
can be used for everything yeah it's an
incredible we we we have it on a very
small scale right now
but eventually we can we're going to
have to go dig up our trash
from dumps and and be able we're going
to be able to use it to make more
graphene
and that's incredible that's so cool so
that that's that's something that we're
going to be able to do
so that's that's a change it's and we're
going to need that for space travel
think about like all the
the trash maybe whatever we come up with
we can make graphene out of it and then
use that graphene
as as hey look you know we had that we
had that plague
what year was the plague 1918 what are
you talking about no no the literal
plague the black player gosh i was like
1300
but after that followed the renaissance
or something didn't it like
you have this level of technology but
everybody
is you know straining for resources then
a large portion of the population dies
because of the plague
but the level the level of technology
remains so then everybody flourishes and
grows rapidly again it's kind of like
breathing like
well that's why that's why elo wants to
occupy mars because we need
we need to expand or that will happen
naturally and that that's i agree with
them we
we absolutely mars mars doesn't have a
magnetic field
and i don't think it has the gravity to
maintain an atmosphere it doesn't matter
we do domes we have to figure out a way
to move on we have to
for sure for sure we we must maybe we uh
just uh underground some training maybe
we you know we do
you know the movie um have you ever seen
red planet
uh they're the first killer yeah yeah
the first people to go to mars i don't
remember
they saw it when it first came out the
robot turns evil or something okay so we
you know what you did we need to combine
the movie the core
was that bruce willis in the core
i don't remember either the who was that
i don't know they have to like
restart the earth's core yes so here's
what we do all right
we take the actors from the movie deep
impact
and the actors from the core and we
bring them together
and they go to mars and they kickstart
the core i don't know i'm just kidding i
don't know how you would
actually do i don't even know it doesn't
make sense no no no no first first you
can
just you know defund hollywood and and
make it more um inspiring for kids to
want to be
the scientists that that come up with
the answers well the hollywood's a great
tool for that
i know but it's not being used correctly
exactly so what we need is people want
to be actors
people want to be influencers they want
to be tick tock stars
youtubers like that is not helping
anything that's
them thinking they are superstars which
is what they say
that's what they've been taught it's i'm
a superstar so i should be able to do
and be famous and it's like okay well
you gotta you gotta have a reason
that people are gonna wanna watch you if
you don't if you don't fill yourself
with
something to give to these people you're
nothing yeah so you gotta make something
of yourself first
and they're they're ignoring that look
at who succeeded
in this open environment pranksters i
can't name one prankster
i can name i'm not gonna personally call
them out okay
but there are a lot of high-profile
prank channels a lot of videos were
getting views but
are they are they still famous they got
banned because youtube was like yo
this is when when left of their own
devices people were like i'm going to
make a video where i go around
saying racial slurs and then i just
worked one up exactly one up each other
so there was a series of videos where
they would go around saying certain
things that sound
like racial slurs when said quickly
enough yeah like hello
my neighbor okay but they would say it
really really fast
and then people would be like what did
you say to me i got a teacher that
that got really mad at me because i said
what the hell teacher
[Laughter]
and they were like how dare you and then
took me to the principal's office the
principal was like get out of here
what are you talking about i was like 11
or something what
this is why i'm not a lazy fair
capitalist but i don't think i would
ever
i think i think the answer is something
like can we come together to fund
movies that inspire people i mean like
interstellar was awesome
i agree great movie we need we need more
cultural cohesion around doing better
but you know
one of the problems is this critical
race theory stuff thinks that science is
evil whiteness that must be abolished
also crazy when elon musk launched that
car into space they were like
look how crazy these billionaires are
wasting waste
he could have you know given people
health care or something and it's like
you realize that money was spent on
earth
right people had jobs yeah they paid
taxes and they they needed
to have weight he was trying to test
that there's something cool and
inspirational
no before that they decided to do that
it was because they needed to have
weight
to test to pay loads right that the
rocket would work
so he was like oh well i'll put a star a
car out there
and you know what it did it did inspire
a bunch of kids
to get into space programs which which
trump brought back the artemis program
it's incredible stuff
like he gave them back their their
funding and i would
i love that what did the obama
administration think was going to happen
we were going to create a consumerist
humanity that just loves plastic yeah
plastic crap
yeah i don't know what the plastic crab
would put a clock in it made in china we
need something better
we need a mission and right now the
mission is this weird religion
intersectionalism right yeah man well if
we don't if we don't get on top of that
what's going to happen to us in 20 years
we're just a bunch of like sunken-eyed
gaunt angry antifa intersectionalists
with shaved heads
i don't think that disease is spreading
as as far as as
well now that the media is slowly
getting above calling it out
as literal white supremacy perhaps it'll
be better
but dude it's in the it's in the army
it's in the federal government
it's in every school it's in every grade
school dude i was
i was out for a christmas dinner a
christmas breakfast with my family
and i was talking to my mom and my
sister about
that equity comic where it shows three
people standing in front of a fence yeah
you know that one
those aren't familiar it's like there's
a tall guy a medium guy and a short guy
and the tall guy and the medium guy can
see and the short guy can't
they said in equality everybody gets a
crate well the tall guy in the medium
guy don't need a crate
in equity they give two crates to the
short guy so he can see now too and i
was
talking about it and i was explaining
why it doesn't make sense and why it's a
manipulation
and my niece who's like eight she goes
they show us that in school
and i was like they do and she was like
yeah i was like this specific image and
she goes yeah they taught us about it
and i was like oh man that is
indoctrination to a religion
eight years old what i explained was
it's very simple to quantify the idea of
equity when you're looking at a fence
with crates
right but now there's like 50 different
versions of this stupid comic explaining
what real justice is
and i said how do you determine how do
you quantify
access and privilege when you're when
you're judging people based on
like 200 000 different immutable
characteristics
are blue eyes better than brown eyes
what if you have crooked teeth what if
you have blonde hair or
what if you're dyed your hair what if
you personally choose to do something
there's no way to quantify that
all right and so i was i was talking to
my family about it but she's being
indoctrinated by your teachers
to believe this critical race theory
stuff equity
so yeah it's pervasive yeah and then why
would anyone want to be
like a who knows like any any sort of a
job if it pays the same as everyone else
you know why would i do that when i
could just do the easier job right
i'll just also do the easy job that's
the problem everyone's just going to
want to do the easy job no one's going
to want to do the hard job
yep and if everything pays the same all
of the
all the hard jobs won't get done anymore
and then society will fall apart
so there needs to be like an aspect and
they're they're not thinking about that
but that's that's the problem uh always
they're not thinking about it they're
ignoring the facts of of what is
actually going on
i think the mixed economy makes the most
sense i do believe
that's what we are aren't we a lot of we
are yeah i do think a lot of people
are not inside they're not motivated by
money some people are motivated by money
and they take jobs where they manipulate
money to make money
i'm not a fan but when it comes to the
ability to hand someone cash and take it
back
well that exists you know people are
going to be able to exploit that right i
do think it's possible
to create a culture where people are
motivated by passion and success for
their mission
less so money yeah it exists because at
a certain point like i know people who
make a ton of money who literally don't
care
because they're like my mission is i got
to build this thing like i'm i'm sure
elon musk isn't focused elon musk isn't
thinking like how can i make a billion
dollars
he's thinking how can i get to mars how
can i occupy mars
exactly it's just he's very blunt about
it however he wants however
elon musk is a man with a mission true
and vision that's true and he worked
really really hard to make this money
and succeed and now he can do it
if you create a society where where
everybody gets paid the same like in
communism
how would you get the visionaries like
elon musk to actually be in that
position
to fund a rocket mission well on an even
more basic level than that
why would you study so hard is to become
something like a doctor
like why would you well why would you
want to do something that's really hard
and has a really high
i don't agree with that well that's
actually no she makes a good point
though that's that's the inverse though
it's that is
the person who wants to learn how to
save people so they're going to push
themselves to become a doctor so that
that's what they're doing
even if they're getting paid the same
they're still they have the
the benefit of getting you know
the reason why people of saving someone
the reason why people would want to do a
job even if it was harder to get to that
jobs position is because they're
passionate about
being a doctor right like i always want
to be a doctor i'll do whatever it takes
but that's not that's
that's that's great no being a doctor
like there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that
sure but that still doesn't take away
the fact that there's all the jobs that
who's going to be the garbage guy right
i say garbage guy
the garbage human you know what you're
going to do garbage person
it's it's really simple and this is what
really really bothers me about you
capitalists
in our communist utopia when someone
when we need someone to take out the
trash and be the garbage
man i just pull out my glock and i point
at them and say get on your knees
and take the trash out otherwise to the
gulag with you
okay problem solved then we have our
utopia
that seems like that'll work and once we
force people to do the jobs that no one
else wants to do
there will be peace
utopia you see that's the issue in a
capitalist system people say i don't
take the trash out
and then you go i'll give you a hundred
bucks and go i'll take the trash out
there you go
boom yeah incentive exactly so that's
why i think a mixed economy makes sense
that's why communism just will never
work because you need
you need a gun and there's always going
to be the person that
thinks that they don't need to do that
that they they're the ones who knows
how to do everything better how to fix
it all or you know
organize and manage actually uh john
over there
he he's the best at taking the trash out
so john's gonna be the trash guy now you
know what i hear pays a ton of money
what
crime scene cleanup really yeah you know
why
because it's hard to get blood out maybe
brain matter and skull [ __ ]
that's right and you're gonna be on the
ground being like let me try and get
this big
brain fragment out of the carpet unless
it's tough crime scene cleanup pays a
lot
huh and how many people are willing to
do that and want to see
i wouldn't want to do that dude people
have no idea what it's like a dead body
you know you know um you know what
happens when you die right
yes brigham artist no when
when all the smooth muscle just relax
relaxes
the gases you void your bowels oh yeah
i'm done so then they they bring in
these people who have these kits and
full hazmat suits
and you get paid a pretty penny because
nobody wants to do it unless you get
paid good enough
i remember when i was uh a lot younger
there was an advertisement for it saying
was like 150 bucks an hour
because that's what you gotta pay when
you get someone to come in and clean up
a corpse yeah and you gotta yeah man
so that's at least people are willingly
you know
are willing to do it because they feel
like they'll be rewarded for it
but in the communist system i i really
don't believe you'll you'll have a
you'll have an easy time finding someone
passionate about waiting around in
sewers
right reminds me of water world remember
that the guy who's in the oil tank
yeah he's one of my favorites so in the
movie water world
they have an oil tanker and there's a
guy who tests his job i just tell him
how much oil they have
so he's just in a little boat in oil
yeah in the oil tank and then
when he calls for help the guy spits on
him and goes thank you
like good luck finding somebody who's
gonna do this job all right
we gotta read super chats thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you